So da sind wir wieder, gucken wir mal ob alles wieder funktioniert
angeblich schon oder twitch gebatet mich wieder
das macht twitch ja ganz gerne
es funktioniert tatsächlich und ich habe sogar wieder qualitätsoptionen
unglaublich
ich habe euch nicht gebatet aber ich glaube twitch hat mich gebatet
so wir müssen jetzt, ich habe auf dem account seiter beta black ops nicht mal am start gehabt
also es könnte sein
als wir jetzt grad mal
sound settings und so ausprobieren müssen
ich mach mal an
bin ich bin ich
ab hier offline
ich weiß dass es noch läuft
wisst ihr
die in was in windows ist das sinnloseste dieses komische notification center
ist mal eine blöde
ernst gemeinte frage an euch
benutzt dieses notification center irgendjemand
für das was es gedacht ist nämlich für notifications ja ich weiß dass man
drüber bluetooth ausschalten kann und sowas
was ich übrigens auch nicht verstehe ist bin aus zehn
warum kann ich auf dem desktop
meinen bildschirm in den tablet modus versetzen
ich meine ist microsoft nicht in der lage zu erkennen dass es nicht auf einem
tablet läuft
das kann aber nicht so schwierig sein
oder was meint ihr
connecting
hat funktioniert
so dass wir gerade mal lautstärke mann ich war mal den
sound hier weg
monke ist
oder wie
wie ging das vorhin
monke ist
oder der bär war auch kein
für monitore mit touch
ok anders gefragt
kann microsoft nicht erkennen
nicht an einem monitor mit
touch ist also
kann das nicht einfach erkennen
wenn der monitor touch hat
erlaubt man diese option
wenn der monitor nämlich kein touch hat ist die option komplett sinnlos
ich weiß nicht aber das ist microsoft
und so
so viel positiv ist ich über microsoft sagen kann
mit windows werde ich wahrscheinlich nie warm werden
und wisst ihr was auch
ich muss jetzt gerade mal die settings gucken
wisst ihr was auch ein komplettes armutszeugnis ist
eier übrigens
übrigens dass meine maus
ihr seht die maus ist oft
seht ihr es
die maus ist oft
die maus ist nicht zentriert
was ist das denn
das ist nicht normales hatte ich muss noch mal ausmachen
das hatte ich vorhin nicht
das sieht man wie kaputt der kram ist
schon zombies gezogen
wie ein großer zombie
zombie
wie nennen die sich irgendwie
die zombie spieler
die
kommandant
sehr gut gemacht
den crash
omega lul
noch mal neustarten
ich meine sagt schon alles
erst mal gelben gestartet
maus zeigen ist nicht richtig dort wurde angezeigt wird zweites mal
gestartet
crash beim start
wird immer besser
was zum teufel ist combat immersion
das game läuft nicht mehr bettel net
doch das game läuft noch
aber angeblich ist es doch aus
kein eines läuft noch
jetzt läuft es nicht mehr
die nvdia treiber sind aktuell nicht kompatibel
tibet
aber ganz davon abgesehen ist nein wir wollen keine safe settings
mal ganz davon abgesehen
es gab sogar vorhin wieder extra den patch zum release von diesem game
ok ich
was ist
game was ist ein problem
gut ist es schön dass ihr das jetzt live mitkriegt wie toll das game wieder
läuft
auf einer skala von müll bis mehr wie viel mülltüten würde es in dem spiel
geben
aber das ist das ist eine trickreiche frage
einmal für die eine für jeden crash beim start
nein wir wollen kein savebot wenn es nicht geht muss ich den komischen
savebot anmachen alle meine
settings neu machen habe ich ja schon bock drauf
ist das wirklich nvdia was den scheiß krascht
kann das sein
ich wüsste zwar nicht warum
okay aber es war die gfos experience auf
okay
das trage ist real
ich bin klar ich muss mal kurz bildschirm ausmachen
so ich bin wieder da
accountpflicht ja
äh übrigens guckt euch mal wie mein account heißt das ging mir so auf den sack
ich musste das irgendwie
mich bei nvdia da bemerkbar machen das mit dass ich eigentlich überhaupt keinen account
will für den kram
okay
dann machen wir jetzt in game overlay aus
jetzt ist aus der komplett aus
denn starten wir es jetzt noch mal
gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
ein
er hat übrigens wisst ihr was auch ein komplettes arme zeugnis ist hierfür
bleib auf vier
das man im jahr 2018 jetzt haltet euch fest
muss man um im duo spielen zu können
ich glaube jetzt geht's da
um duo spielen zu können also sprich um eine lobby aufzumachen
muss einer von beiden sich ports weiter leiten auf seinem router
wir sind im jahr 2018
fällt euch noch
wir lassen was so rocke wieder wie vor einer weg
irgendein anderes game ein was das 2018 brauche
erzhaft gibt's ja irgendwas
rainbow six
läuft ja auch irgendwie zur hälfte p2p na
aber
so als muss ich wahrscheinlich meine settings neu machen
aber das lobby system wenigstens nicht
sind meine settings denn richtig zeigt mal her
foff wie ist mein foff
mein foff ist 100 das ist schon mal ganz gut das sieht richtig aus
monitor
ja ok
des render resolution ssb ja das sieht alles gut aus unlimited frame
brightness bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
Down
Slider end auf
vier perfekt
So nach zehn minuten haben wir es geschafft das spiel zu starten nice sehr nice
Die wollte ich anlocken
Was taugt eigentlich hier so gut
Ja
Fällt mal auf dass irgendwie das rum packt ja genau was ich ausprobieren wollte ist wie das mit diesem
diesem operator mod ist weil die
Es steht ja auch nirgendswo dazu was genau dieser operator macht
Also es gibt so eine special park dann kann man wenn man die waffe auf max level hat kann man diesen diesen diesen operator
operator mod verwenden
Das sind welche und die katz läuft hier um ganz was los
Ich muss eben ich muss eben schon ein bisschen gucken die katz hat in letzter zeit ein bisschen rumgekotzt
Ich habe kein bock dass die katzin jetzt irgendwo hinkotzt
Macht sie nicht gut sie geht aufs klo nice macht das mal
Ja das ding ist die smg sind in dem game relativ schwach
So wir versuchen mal mit dem ding ein bisschen weiter weiter freizuschalten das kann nicht sein dass das komplett sagt
Und ich finde das hier ist eine ganz gute anti bullshit kombi eigentlich
Flag checket tactical mask dann ist man von ein paar sachen sicher groß an die kill streaks was angeblich verpackte sind nicht funktioniert
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute anti bullshit das natürlich muss die gegner mitspielen so aus gore streaks was nehmen wir, wir nehmen uav, wir nehmen helstorm und wir nehmen
Dem lightning strikes so und eine sache müssen wir noch ändern dieser stim shot ist irgendwie gar nicht
wirklich notwendig ich dachte am anfang dass man den stim shot braucht dass man sich überhaupt mit x heilen kann aber anscheinend kann man sich immer mit x heilen das heißt
Die logische konsequenz daraus wäre eigentlich man nimmt den akustik sensor mit
Kannste nicht kotzen
Die logische schlussfolgerung heraus wäre eigentlich man nimmt den akustik sensor mit dass wir die gegner besser hatten so was wie freefall
Man nimmt das ding mit für niedrige kill streaks oder man nimmt die habe ich noch nie gespielt
Body armor wir probieren jetzt mal aus das ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie juggernaut ist wahrscheinlich voll verpönt also voll verpönt
das ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie wie mp40 juggernaut oder sowas body armor das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Gucken ob das was taugt wahrscheinlich mache ich das eh nach einer runde wieder weg
Aber nachdem man den heal eh hat
Und so oft sich healen dass man das stim pack braucht
Gibt es eigentlich gar nicht weil entweder verreckt man oder man heilt sich einmal und ist nicht quasi in der stimmpeg
verreckt man oder man heilt sich einmal und ist nicht quasi innerhalb von drei sekunden fünf mal verrecken
Ich muss mal gucken was die katz machen weil ich habe kein bock dass sie irgendwo hinkommt
Die hat sich jetzt ein neues hobby meine katze die setzt sich von fernsee den fette sony fernsee und ich glaube meine katze denkt der fernsee ist ein fennsler und die will da immer youtube videos drauf gucken und das ist kein witz
Die setzt sich von fernsee den fette sony fernsee und ich glaube meine katze denkt der fernsee ist ein fennsler und die will da immer youtube videos drauf gucken und das ist kein witz meine katze guckt halt drauf youtube videos auf dem fernsee setzt sich dann davor und guckt auf den fernsee und dann weiß ich ich muss jetzt youtube videos anmachen und zwar nicht etwa irgendwelche youtube videos sondern das sehen wir jetzt mal
den schild dude den op dude nehmen wir mal sondern die will dass ich ihr eichhörnchen oder vögelvideos anmache die ist da sehr wählerisch also ich kann das nicht einfach irgendwie ich kann das nicht keine ahnung aporet oder so anmachen und meiner katze gefällt das nein ich muss acht stunden eichhörnchen anmachen oder sowas und das findet die geil da setzt sie sich vor den fernsehen guckt sie acht stunden guckt sich acht stunden eichhörnchen an
sag mir mal wie die lautstärke ist gleich ich selbst höre relativ wenig sag mal sollte ich nicht body armor haben und mehr leben sollte ich nicht mehr leben haben fuck ich dachte man kann da rüberspringen dachte man kann da kann man nicht
die spritze ist am besten man hat doch immer eine spritze man hat auch immer eine spritze das ist das was ich nicht verstehe
man hat doch immer eine spritze monkaS monka kika
aber ich muss wieder erstmal ein bisschen reinkommen hier wieder
das war das war doch der radiator ist ein typische video gespielter blätzen ja ich weiß was die spritze macht aber die braucht man eigentlich gar nicht also habe ich zumindest den eindruck jetzt gewonnen
ja ja ist gut macht dann rum gejumpen weiter guck ich meine spritze sind wir da wenn man was braucht
da kommt einer kommst du raus was habt ihr gesehen wieder vorbei geruckelt ist
fack aber man warum haben die nicht gehauen max wolltest du nicht das stimmt habe ich ob die richtige klasse ausgerüstet ich bin verwirrt ich glaube ich habe die falsche klasse kann das sein
ich glaube ich habe die falsche klasse ich habe die falsche klasse habe ich auch meine rüstung dabei
ja besser erstmal kills konformen was wird das hinter mir gesporn black ops
blies was ist das wollte ich verarschen das ist ja der mega g bade war das
ok jetzt ok leute ich gebe zu die spritze ist doch sehr praktisch fack ich kenne die
map nicht wo geht es lang hier irgendwo das ding ist bestimmt das hipfire biest schlechthin
ich kann über die range nichts machen vergesst die range sagt ich hasse diese
one hand sniper one hand sniper blies muss das sein was ist das
sniper typ die türken das andere geht sich über sniper auf es ist auch absolut fack
ich habe unspaßige spielmechanik hoch 10 one shot waffen ist einfach so in jedem
game sind one shot waffen du hallo und und blies wo bist du kann er mal gerade auslaufen
die sind im spawn ich fass nicht das game macht mich jetzt schon wieder verrückt guck
es euch an guck es euch an wie gut die shotgun sind gute frage keine ahnung nächste frage
ich verpiss mich komm hier rein hipfire alter lull die schlecht
da kommt eine granate bei
wie ist nicht wie ist nicht wie er nicht gestorben das habt ihr gesehen wie viel ich
ihm reingedrückt habe man warum sind satmaschinen ganz was von keis
typischer kotter in die eine richtung denkst du gehts und in die andere richtung kriegst
auf die fresse ich wusste so viel spiel das ding ist halt im nahkampf geil aber die sache
ist das ding ist so durchgeslided so merkwürdig durch der 21 geht doch aber 21 wird es nicht
so der wahnsinn so komisch auf range irgendwie die sind ein sniper schuss wirst du noch mal
mit dem typ ab welcher sniper schuss was meinst du 18er kimbo ja das ist die letzte smg mit
der man das glaube ich machen kann ob das ist die hier aber nicht ganz sicher ich glaube
es ist hier ja du wehlt das heißt man erst mal auf level 10 level und dann geht das echo
feier ja mal hier solt reife optik erinnert mich doch gerne an das schott kann der kimbo
ist ja also in dieser hinrichtung auch so der in der gipfel mw2 kannst ja erst mal die
was war ich genau die die die models waren aus 18 18 87 model die konstant fange kimbo
tragen dadurch dass sie ja kimbo genommen hast du quasi ein halber kilometer mit der
schott kann man schottet also im sekunden im halben sekundentakt und danach haben sie
es ja gefixt danach haben sie es ja gefixt in mw2 und danach muss es da einfach noch
ein weiteres attachment drauf machen das war noch mehr op als vorher das ist auch so eine
bullshit sache die hier ein bisschen blöd ist in dem game es gibt so ein typ der kann
der kann minen legen also es gibt einmal wohl so eine mine die man auslegen auslösen kann
und was halt auch richtig nervig sind diese die die moderneren tripwires also mit die
laser tripwires quasi die siehst du nicht die siehst du wirklich wenn die gut platziert
sind du siehst sie nicht die siehst du schlechter als jede klamour kotlobby sind immer noch
per to per aber sicher sind kotlobby ist noch per to per wir machen jetzt revolver action
und deswegen finde ich es ist wichtig dass man die es gibt mit 42 mit level 42 wohlgemerkt
gibt es eine frag granate mit 42 und dann kann man das austauschen spricht dann kann
ich jetzt hier von dem operator nämlich seine der hat so einen spawn bieken problem ist
halt team des man spawn bieken ist komplett für den arsch ja die map kenn ich ist neu
noch nicht gespielt schatten gesehen toll weg
wo geht ihr mal sterben
was hinter mir
bitte noch unfaire response was soll denn das sein
jetzt kann ich so komische spawn bingen setzen der eigentlich was bringt in tdm
wo geht hier auf der map bitteschön was ab
dieses game ich weiß auch nicht wo es lang geht trotz dem jetzt kann es nicht sein
war nein bang das ding ist der op ist so shit aller zeiten
umfall sounds kann man da hoch scheinlich nicht da ich muss kills konform
das kriegst du zu langsam streak punkte
oder hinter mir
jetzt hier lang
immer von hinten alter kotz please
immer von der seite gebraucht immer
guckt man mal man hört ja auch keine schritte vielleicht nehme ich mir ich
nehme als nächstes diese schritte sensording mit
weiß natürlich das ganze team wo ich bin
erinnere mich mal dran nächste runde nehme ich das das schritte schritte lautstärke
immer von der seite immer das kann es doch echt nicht sein
kannst ja nicht mehr als zwei kills machen wenn du rumläufst
man muss ja hin das einfach verschwunden gerade
da kann man nicht mehr stellen das stimmt
ist auch das was mich am meisten bisher nervt dass man eigentlich überhaupt nicht bedenken
kann gar nicht mehr wo gegner sind du hast halt nix in der beta war das noch lauter das
haben sie absichtlich leise gesagt ja konfirm du das mal du machst das schon
fliegt er weg er fliegt einfach weg habt ihr es gesehen erst weggeflogen
okay dann nicht dass jetzt hätten wir schön außen können mit dem mit dem revolver
pogas richtiger pogas kein pogas ein pogas
gibt es jetpack nein es gibt kein jetpack zum glück gibt es kein jetpack wenn ich mir
diese sachen hier mit jetpack noch vorstellen dann wäre komplett aus dann
wäre wirklich vorbei das war nicht mal der typ vor mir das wäre irgendwie so ein so
random typ daneben
da gehe ich nicht hin ich weiß nicht wo er ist
komm ich nehm wieder weg
das haben sie von von overwatch hier
also hardcore hat sich für mich in keinem kompessor gut gespielt man merkt meistens
hardcore anders es nicht so ist wie es wie es sich dass die hersteller gedacht haben
weil was noch manchmal weniger hat und weniger minimap und da ging doch so lange ich bei
meiner 3r kd bleibt weil wir wissen ja call of duty spieler müssen auf die kd gucken bin
ich zufrieden also wollen wir irgendwas ändern ja wir wollten anscheinend bodyarmer wollen
wir mal das ding ausprobieren oder probieren wir probieren mal das wir probieren mal das
das schneller kill streaks ding aus gucken wir das so ist durchprobieren ja und ob team
link wirklich was bringt bin ich auch irgendwie weiß nicht
ist das ein iphone 10 was das ja es hat schon gewisse ähnlichkeiten muss man sagen das
ist die gelände edition outdoor extreme survival zombie apocalypse edition was ist eigentlich
max level kein schimmer wahrscheinlich wieder 50 oder so danach ganz wahrscheinlich wieder
prestigen bis bis zum geht nicht mehr das ist auch so eine komische map da gibt es
in der mitte ein schiff dass das wo man auf bild kann sieht und drumherum sind die spawns
auch wieder ganz wir also typische call of duty spawns einer links eine rechts und dann
bist du in der mitte vom schiff los gerannt auf einmal sind die gegner hinter dir gespornet
weil ich das auch nicht verstehe also spawns ist eine geschichte die kriegen sie ja irgendwie
gefühlt schon seit von call of duty oder so nicht so als erst mal erst mal schön hier
warten bis die gegner kommen kommen sie nämlich gleich rechts ran zumindest in dem fall nicht
jetzt kommen sie von hinten guckt leute jetzt ist geflippt jetzt kommen sie von hinten
und jetzt kommen sie wieder andere richtung die spawns ich werde verrückt das ist das
was ich am anfang der runde gemeint habe mit spawns auf der map da da da da
immer von der seite
jetzt habe ich ihn geflasht
ich komme jetzt von hinten wieder ich sage es euch
krasse sparen sie noch meiner aber einer komm her komm her
die spawn jetzt wieder hier sag so ich wenn keiner hinguckt so klar kacke spawns kacke
spawns alter diese kacke spawns so ein räudiger kacke das ist so schlimm du kannst es überhaupt
nicht erahnen wo was herkommt
da wollte ich nicht gar nicht lang und jetzt sparen sie bestimmt wieder hier ich sage
es euch jetzt ist natürlich so schnell dass ich mal hinterher kommen die kommen sich jetzt
auch übelst verarscht vorne kommt her
jetzt werden sie geschreckt
kommst du her
ich
schaffte
Achtung der wird jetzt gefickt der Typ
Achtung Achtung BÄÄÄM
Alter kott immer von der seite
Die haben wir gerekt gerade.
Erinnert mich mal dran, dass die Runde speicher nach der, im Kino speicher nach der, nach dem es vorbei ist.
Man kann sich, man kann sich rund ein Book marken, die man dann quasi im Kino nochmal abspielen lassen kann.
Ihr kommt bestimmt von da.
Fast.
Immer in, immer in die Seite gebashed.
Macht das Game Spaß?
Ja prinzipiell.
Der AD, AD Spam ist strong.
Muss weg.
Hallo, hochspringen, krasse Elite Soldat, beweg dich.
Wenn du immer eins gegen drei und so sind, du kriegst die einfach nicht schnell genug tot.
Kill confirmed.
Okay, shit.
Na gut, in Kot ist halt das Wort Team in TDM so eine Sache für sich.
Also, ich meine wirklich, Team ist da eigentlich nie so am Start.
So, Book marken, Game Book marken.
Die Robbe macht gerade gar nichts.
Die Robbe ist noch nicht richtig warm geworden.
Alter, 161 Leute, was geht jetzt ab ey.
Pogas.
Äh, Bookmark.
Hier, müsst ihr euch merken, ganz wichtig, wenn man ein gutes Game hatte, kann man das sich bookmarken, dass man es nachher wieder findet.
Weil ansonsten ist die Übersicht im Kino-Modus ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig irgendwie.
Ich habe sogar ein Nightbot-Command für die Robbe, stimmt's?
Ganz vergessen.
Ähm.
Also, wir hatten jetzt dieses Killstreak-Reduzier-Ding.
Hat das was gebracht, was meint ihr?
Wir hatten einmal alle unsere Streaks, aber gefühlt hätte ich die auch ohne gekriegt.
Was meint ihr, taugt das?
Hat das was gebracht?
Wir können doch nochmal eine Runde spielen.
Der M-Core!
Ist das der reale M-Core?
Der echte.
Der richtig echte.
Krass, der M-Core ist am Start, nice.
Was machst du denn gerade so?
Ich habe eben nichts mal gehört.
Was nehmen wir denn eigentlich?
Ich warte wirklich nur bis ich 42 bin, weil eigentlich gefällt mir Seraph am besten.
Wegen dieser geilen One-Kill.
One-Shot-Revolver.
Das ist eigentlich das geilste.
Also am OP-sten ist Ajax mit dem Schild.
Okay, welche Map war das jetzt nochmal?
Ach die, wo sich alle über die Seiten wäschen.
Ich lasse mal meine Leute vor.
Okay.
Oh, NA.
NA des Todes.
Selten so NA geaimt worden, oder?
Ah, da geboxt.
Da haben wir das Almedia-Challenge im anderen Shop.
Ich mache immer noch das gleiche wie ich früher auch gemacht habe.
Ich höre da was rennen.
One-KS.
Hier ist übelst gefährlich.
Okay, das war nicht die beste.
Die kommen jetzt nämlich wieder von hinten.
Weil, ja weil Spawns und so, weil Black Ops.
Och man sterbt halt mal Leute.
Sterbt mal.
Ist ja nicht so, ich meine ich treffe auch nicht gut.
Ja, muss man auch mal sagen.
Es ist ja auch so.
Komm raus.
Come on brah.
Move dich.
Okay, hat keinen Bock.
Alter, scheiß Hipfire, wie schlecht ist das?
Oh, wie mies.
Ich habe jetzt voll Leistungsdruck, weil du zuguckst.
Gegner, please.
Gegner.
Alter, wie geht es denn hier weiter?
Oben, oben, oben, okay.
Da gehe ich doch jetzt nicht raus, ich glaube es geht los.
Hast du einen Chopper oder sowas?
Gegner Chopper?
Nein, freundlicher Chopper, okay.
Das sollten wir eigentlich easy winnen.
Alter, Spawn, please.
Gegner.
Alter.
Ihr steigt euch nicht durch, wo was herkommt.
Ihr steigt euch echt nicht durch.
Jetzt müssten sie eigentlich von da kommen, oder?
Oh Mann.
Vielleicht versuche ich das auch einfach mit zu viel Hirn zu spielen.
Und man muss einfach drauf rennen.
Okay, prefire das Todes.
Achtung, Pistolenaction.
Hätte ja seither funktionieren können.
Das kann ja nicht jede Runde so gut laufen.
Das gibt es doch nicht, meine Aim ist so scheiße manchmal.
Scheibenwischer.
Ist ja fast als würde ich einen Xbox-Controller spielen.
Übrigens, was ich cool finde, man spawnt relativ schnell.
NA-Aim, ja.
Das ist nicht NA-Aim, das ist schon US-Aim.
Ich dachte da war jemand.
War aber anscheinend nicht.
Okay.
Shotgun, das hat mir gefehlt.
True Elmo, ich würde warten.
Also mich fuckt das Game ja ab.
Ich meine, es macht Spaß, ja.
Aber es ist halt typisches Cod-Gameplay.
Aber ich habe mich gestern gefragt, was wäre denn, wenn man jeglichen Bullshit aus Cod entfernen würde.
Was wäre dann?
Das wäre kein Cod mehr.
Das ist Big-Prain-Logik.
Was?
Ich habe das gefixt.
Was sagst du zu dem Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis von i9 9900K?
Denkst du es lohnt sich, den jetzt schon zu kaufen?
Ich weiß nicht, was kostet der denn?
Was kostet der?
Mit dem Lid kann man ja mal gucken.
Ah, man sollte i vielleicht doch i schreiben.
Das ist aber ordentlich.
1.700K kostet die Hälfte, und was hat der?
Der hat ungefähr den gleichen Takt wie ein 8700.
Ein Ticken mehr, aber nicht wirklich viel.
Und wie viel Cores?
8 Kerne?
Das ist zu teuer, also wenn du spielen willst, würde ich das nicht machen.
Man muss ja sagen, dass der 8700, sogar der ist eigentlich schon Overkill.
Der 8700 hat 6 Kerne.
8 Kerne ist nice, ohne Frage.
Aber, wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie viele Sachen Games verwenden, kann man das ja mal machen.
Wie das mit Black Ops aussieht.
Black Ops braucht gerade im Prinzip ein Kern oder so.
Das ist das Hauptmenü.
Aber du wirst kaum Games finden, die von 8 Kernen profitieren.
StarCraft z.B. profitiert von Kernen.
Eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht.
Das Ding hat mir zu wenig Wumms, die Waffe irgendwie.
Komm, wir spielen mal was anderes.
Was macht einen schönen Damage?
Nehmen wir mal das Ding.
Mir fällt auf dem Desktop auch nicht viel ein, wozu man 8 Kerne bräuchte.
Die einzigen Sachen, die es da so gibt, sind ganz Hardcore-Photoshop-Leute.
Oder eben Leute, die 3D-Geschichten machen.
Selbst Videorendern ist fraglich, ob da 8 Kerne so viel besser sind als 6 Kerne.
Du machst die Mega-Auflösung und die Mega-Bitrate und so.
Auf der Map habe ich nie eine Ahnung, wie man den Opener am besten macht.
Links rum oder über die Brücke.
Gefühlt halten alle mehr aus als ich.
Suche Gegner.
Kack Iron Sight.
Das weiß natürlich jeder, wo ich bin.
Achtung, Wallbang.
Nein.
Warum gestellt sie hier?
Wallhack.
Achtung.
Die Mann kann Damage.
Und jetzt kommt einer von hinten.
Moment Leute, Achtung.
Run and Gun.
Tschüss, M-Core.
Gegner.
Wo ist er hin?
Geil, jetzt habe ich eine halbe Stunde verfolgt und jetzt ist er tot.
Ich bin einfach der Run and Gunner.
Eigentlich wollte ich springen.
Achtung, Achtung.
Nein.
Scheiße.
Wie gerade gesagt wird.
Achtung.
Das ist aber gerade nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Warum bin ich zweiter?
Ich bin so schlecht.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Alter, schreck mich jetzt so.
Haha, erschreckt.
Was ist das denn da?
Nein.
So geht es.
Das war das Beste.
Was ist das für ein Foff, ich glaube 100.
Was ist das für ein Bullshit wieder?
Flank tot, Flank tot.
Eigentlich müsste es immer Turpel-Kell sein.
Flank, bam, drei weg, bam, drei weg, bam, drei weg, bam, drei weg, bam, drei weg.
Was zur Hölle?
Flank.